des chantiers écologique il ya d'autres
très bons plans en bourgogne franche
comté nous le prouvons avec jérémy dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord nous
allons dans la bibliothèque de typhaine
qui n'a pas son pareil pour nous
suggérer quelques idées lecture pour nos
enfants et ça s'est toujours bien
d'autant que là vous avez vous avez des
livres délirant dont le point commun est
de s'inspirer de la pop culture ce soir
oui pascal vous savez la pop culture
c'est cet ensemble de rock'n'roll de
dessins animés de super héros et de
street art un ensemble un peu cohérent
qui s'est construit depuis les années 50
et qui permet d'avoir des références
communes et de les détourner
et justement ce livre la malédiction des
flamants roses propose aux jeunes
lecteurs de suivre la création d'un
livre alors ça commence très simplement
on nous présente qui va écrire ce livre
alors il ya alice de nuit si l'auteur il
y as janik coat l'illustratrice et
valeria pour les éditions grasset le
problème c'est qu'elle ne se comprennent
pas toujours et que leur héros ne sont
pas très disciplinés ils veulent chacun
avoir le premier rôle
il n'aime pas les décors qu'on leur
propose alors il commence à discuter
chacun pour pouvoir se placer au mieux
alors vous voyez ceux qui préfèrent le
pôle nord il y a ceux qui voudraient
plutôt un paysage - moins froid alors
vous vous retrouvez dans un livre
complètement délirant addictif et vous
voulez absolument savoir ce qu'il se
passe alors c'est vraiment un livre que
je conseille aux enfants à partir de 5
ans car c'est un format xxl
vous voyez les couleurs sont dignes de
warhol c'est vraiment très très drôle
je ne vais pas vous raconter la forme
donc vous la thur une fois qu'on n'aura
pas le temps
et bien c'est le flamant rose tiens à
propos de fraudes
vous savez comment dorin flamants roses
de typhaine serait une date
oui oui oui sur une ou deux pattes la
tête cachée sous son aile et son cri
ressemble à celui d'une oie voilà pour
être très précis parce qu'il ya beaucoup
qui se posaient la question je vous
ferai pas le cri de l'oie
mais en revanche vous vous allez nous en
dire un peu plus sur votre deuxième
sélection c'est un livre
très surprenant des aventures
intersidéral et je devine dans ce qui
est marqué je devine l'ourson biloute
c'est ça oui intersidéraux parce que
vous allez être sidéré si vous lisez
déjà trouvé le mobile août dans le titre
d'un livre
ça peut surprendre alors biloute c'est
un petit terme affectueux du nord et
c'est le nom de cette oursons nés de
l'imagination de deux cousins julien et
renault d'aylmer qui vous emmène dans
les hautes france et cet ourson on
découvre un complot blast vador
s'apprête à envahir la france et le
monde
alors il s'adjoint les services de super
héros de bikers et même d'un enfant arc
en ciel pour éviter ça alors c'est un
livre complètement délirant avec des
illustrations façon comics et vous allez
voir c'est très très drôle vraiment je
le conseille aux enfants à partir de 8
ans mais je conseille aux parents de le
lire avec eux car c'est bourré de
références aux années 70 il ya même une
bande son à la fin donc ça permettra aux
parents et aux enfants et bien de
découvrir ensemble des morceaux de rock
c'est très très drôle
il ya du dialecte chimiques et para qui
ont parsemé dans le livre vraiment je
vous le conseille et ça regroupe cinq
aventures à la manière d'épisodes de
séries télé on est dans la faculté et
nous on aime le titre parce que c'est un
affectueux du nord kivu dit ça quand on
pense biloute on pense aux ch'tis on
pense à dany boon on pense à line renaud
et y est on y est quoi un ça y est on y
est vous nous avez fait pleuvoir ce
matin dit dans un bon allez on va mettre
un petit peu de soleil on va quitter le
méchant blast vador finalement il faut
pas le confondre avec dark vador c'est
ça si j'ai bien compris parce que
j'étais moi ce matin dans le monde
intersidéral pour une autre aventure aux
confins de la galaxie vous nous emmenez
ou est-ce qu'il ya encore des références
à la pop culture à star wars la guerre
des étoiles pour terminer
pascal aujourd'hui on est à fond dans
l'espace je vous emmène avec ce livre
qui s'appelle la honte de la galaxie
d'alexis braud cas je vous emmène en 300
milles donc on fait un bond dans le
futur
et là où de la galaxie s'appelle berry
masse est une jeune soldate qui s'est
exilé on ne sait pas exactement pourquoi
mais elle a commis une grande faute mais
son rêve c'est quand même de visiter
mixte alors un x 100 une planète en
ensemble de planète puisque tous les
humains sont répartis sur des planètes
et on découvre en fait de nouvelles
civilisations des êtres extraterrestre
évidemment il y à des courses en
vaisseau spatial des armes terrifiantes
c'est très drôle c'est déjanté je vous
le conseille on retrouve l'imaginaire
spatiale forget boulogne car si sûr
c'est un bon course aux cultures c'est
sarbacane allez-y c'est le salon merci
people et j'aime beaucoup votre appart
un vraiment sympa le décor et c'est
chouette c'est notre plage senut et
merci tiphaine la sélection livre à
retrouver aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur france 3 point fr pour le replay
on sourit parce que voilà on n'a qu'une
vie et on en profite